[Music]
hello and welcome to crosstalk where all
things are considered i'm peter lovell
the putin biden summit has come and gone
but biden's real
message on his european tour was to
galvanize washington's allies into some
kind of anti-china alliance
did he succeed also the january 6 riot
the fbi and the ark of history
[Music]
to discuss these issues and more i'm
joined by my guest
george samueli in budapest he is a
podcaster at the goggle
which can be found on youtube rumble and
locals
and here in moscow we're joined by
dmitry bobbitt he is a political analyst
and editor at innos me internet media
project
all right gentlemen crosstalk rules in
effect that means you can jump anytime
you want and i always appreciate it
okay let's go to start off with dima
here in moscow as well
uh demon you and i and george discuss
the content of what we were going to do
on this program yesterday and you sent
me an email
with some comments and you said we
should title this program
china europe's unwanted enemy
why did you suggest that because i
thought it was very interesting go ahead
well it's absolutely clear that
european countries especially germany
which has
a huge economic ties you know to
china and east european countries which
absolutely do not want to have
confrontation with china
these countries are not interested in
the anti-chinese
rhetoric and wars and chinese actions
which are basically forced on them by
washington
i mean some of these countries don't
have to be persuaded to be anti-russian
i think it was a huge mistake you know
when
the russian foreign policy for many
years stated that
somehow the united states is more
hostile to russia than the european
union there are some countries in in
eastern europe which are certainly
more anti-russian than the united states
but they don't want to fight
china and and when uh at the last uh
the recent nato meeting china was de
facto declared an enemy let me quote it
china's stated ambitions and assertive
behavior present
systemic challenges to the rules-based
international order
and areas relevant to nato's security
and of course in nato's language that
means china is an enemy
because who presents systemic challenges
and and also it's a big lie because in
what way
can china threaten nato i mean
militarily militarily nato is many times
stronger than china and china is located
in a completely different part of the
world
and china during the last at least
40 years china did not invade other
countries it did not take
any territory under its control it did
not democratize
any foreign nation it was not involved
in nation building
and still you know china is viewed as
hostile by the united states
and certainly it reminded me of the
situation that uh
you know we saw during the world war ii
when nazi germany
had powerful allies in in europe such as
italy such as hungary such as finland
they were not interested in in outside
geology and in
establishing german world order i mean
finns wanted to take pedro zavozco
carelli
the areas next to them but they didn't
want to take leningrad you know
italians wanted to uh have some part of
greek territory they wanted to
cut yugoslavia to size but they didn't
want to die
on the vulgar germans forced them i mean
germans forced the finns to participate
in the siege of landing ground
and germans forced italians to die near
stalingrad
so there was independence when you when
you surrendered to a hostile ideology
to a very radical ideology they got a
lot more than they bargained for rules
faced order we
demon just read that quote george i
wonder who wrote that and who's on the
rules-based order tour
okay now one of the reasons i wanted to
do this george because i think it's very
very interesting
um number one um joe biden is president
america is back but well not
everybody wants even with it within the
european union
within nato want wants america back the
way it was before
but see what's happening in the way i
look at it is this huge
cleavage is big it's very small now but
it's going to grow and grow and grow
because
the us is the master of nato undoubted
okay what they want they get
okay the european union is different
okay
you can you can have this threat um
inflation these imaginary threats you
know we have to spend all this money
because of
the russian threat but when it comes to
economics you're a little bit more
hard-headed and sober okay and just as
deema pointed out i mean
um why are we conflating these all
things together and then china is the uh
uh the obvious enemy it's not obvious
whatsoever go ahead george
right no i think there's there are many
issues there um
there's without question first of all
the issue that uh
nato is continually looking for
a new role so it has to always be one
step
ahead of the curve you know thinking
about what's the next uh threat that we
can justify our continued existence
but the communique that was issued uh
the other day
was still basically focused on russia
russia i mean there was paragraph
after paragraph after paragraph about
all the terrible things
russia has done all the terrible threats
that russia poses
russia's cheating here russia's
violating this and so on
so yes china is mentioned but that comes
down to
something like paragraph 55 or something
and the language is much
more circumspect you know yes china is a
uh a challenge
we really have to uh look upon it but
then the
it says and china is cooperating
militarily with russia that that's
it's uh that's the point george don't
you think i mean
because nato is essentially just a
propaganda
operation okay and so slowly but surely
they're
it's the overton window all over again
can essentially what they want to do is
they want to conflate
china with russia they start they want
to see them as
inseparable yes that's right the more
they do that
the more russian china will come
together which these people don't seem
to have any clear-sighted understanding
about them go ahead
no it's very much like these two powers
are threats to the rules-based order
and and they even and they mentioned
something like well china is a
challenging the values-based washington
treaty the treaty that set up
nato um so there is that now there's no
question the united states sees china as
a major geopolitical rival
it's an emerging economic giant and the
united states
really doesn't like it because they it
feels that china will become the
economic and financial
power in the world in in the in the
coming decades and that will be the end
of the dollars
uh role in the world system so yes
no question i mean this happened already
under obama much more so under trump
you know the united states wants to uh
pitch the hostility
towards china but the europeans they are
essentially a regional
powers they're all regionals they don't
think globally i mean yeah
russia they can think about that there's
a history there and of course as deemer
pointed out i mean there's
all of those states that are absolutely
rapidly anti-russian the baltic states
and poland
um but they can't really get wrap their
heads around
china i mean china's nowhere near europe
and so it's very
hard for them to go along with this even
though the united states without
question is trying to push them in this
direction
okay you know again you know if we make
the juxtaposition to the cold war
um uh there was virtually no trade
between the west and the soviet union i
mean it was
that's one of the conditions here and
but this new cold war if we can use that
term
that washington wants to push the
europeans toward
visa v china well the china is the eu's
biggest trading partner
okay and again we can go about you know
um uh um threats that are phantoms and
all that
but trade is not a phantom it's very
very real
okay and europe as it is trying to pull
itself out of this
um uh a pandemic needs trade
and and china was very much open to it
they can't have it
both ways at the same time and this is
what washington is telling them
you know you have to have it both ways
at the same time and it's completely
impractical go ahead
well uh washington keeps saying uh we
will make russia
pay a price you know that was their
slogan for many years
now it looks like first they made the eu
pay the price because it was not the
united states who imposed sanctions on
russia
and for whom these sanctions were really
uh really painful
it was the eu which has uh which is the
biggest
uh trading partner russia who lost
billions you know at least 100 billions
were lost
on on anti-russian sanctions in the
first year
you know and and later there were more
and more horses
so the eu will pay the price and with
china that price is going to be several
times higher than with russia
but you know it's it's a lesson you have
to learn from history
when you join an aggressive extremist
ideology and unfortunately
the people like victoria nuland the
people like uh
john brennan they have an extremist
ideology the moment when you
liaise with them you lose you should
prepare for huge
losses uh poland obviously wanted the
united states to help them cut
russia to size that that was their idea
they wanted to
to be strong you know with the united
states behind them okay the united
states is behind them
and the united states is now cancelling
their
possibly luxurious deals with china
that's what is happening you know and
with greece
it's even more obvious because greece is
very very much liaised with china
economically
they sold them several of their ports
you know in in greece
so indeed it's going to be painful and
the problem is that uh this is the price
of ideology
i mean yeah and also this is the price
of lies i mean look at the
way uh uh american liberal press
covered uh biden's visit you know uh i
almost vomited
the washington post uh mike's boot biden
wiped the smirk of putin's face
by them knew how to deal with the uh
kremlin strongman he did it much better
than trump who's sympathetic and coward
i mean
the whole idea of presenting biden putin
meeting as some
kind of a boxing match in which joe has
to stand up
to that you know that's so stupid that's
okay
but that was the the the main theme of
the media in the last two weeks
yeah i mean i did i didn't realize that
max boot writes for the babylon b
or the onion because that's i read the
article thank you demon for sending to
me
and it's completely satirical i mean if
you didn't know better you'd say this is
a joke right
yes well i think the problem is that
people like uh
max boot have a problem on their hands
uh they spent the last uh four or five
years
making these claims that trump is a
traitor trump is selling out the country
trump
is uh working for putin uh
trump is uh treasonous any any
uh gesture by uh trump towards russia
even even when he's imposing sanctions
even when he's kicking out diplomats is
really secretly a plot uh
by putin uh to to throw us off the scene
so that they've been peddling this
nonsense for four or five years
now they have biden uh their man you
know they rejoice that trump has been
defeated so he's their man
and he's being friendlier than of course
the russians than
trump was george they have to double
back and come up with some convoluted
nonsense as to why
it's okay when biden does it but it's
terrible when trump does it
so but in the last 25 seconds george
if trump had had this same exact summit
with putin he would be a traitor
but biden having his experience
is a noble um democratic um
diplomatic leader it's it's max boot
does actually show
the incredible bias and how dangerous
that bias is when it comes to american
foreign policy
it's all about their perceptions and to
echo edema
their ideology all right gentlemen i'm
going to jump in here we're going to go
to a short break and after that short
break we'll continue our discussion on
some real news stay with rt
[Music]
welcome back to crosstalk where all
things are considered i'm peter lovell
to remind you we're discussing
some real news and this is the home
[Music]
edition
all right let's go back to uh george in
budapest
george it's because it's slowly but
surely being revealed
as we approach the january six trials i
mean hundreds of people
potentially are going to go on trial
here and it's being revealed
that a lot of there's a lot of unnamed
co-conspirators
and well people are wondering why are
their names redacted
and is it because they had contact with
the authorities with the fbi
specifically and that is very very
troubling
but what's even more troubling is that
the legacy
liberal media points a finger at you
saying
well you must be a conspiracy conspiracy
theorist for asking
those questions the media won't ask
those questions we're left to ask those
questions go ahead george
yes it's very interesting because what
has happened
this week is a sudden
sea change in the uh story
of the events of january the 6th and it
reminds me of what happened um
some point in 2017 with the trump russia
uh story when devin nunes uh suddenly
disclosed
that the uh fbi surveillance warrant
uh of carter page was based entirely
on the steele dossier this was a
shocking disclosure
um and of course the legacy media and
all the pundits and all the
ex-fbi and cia people said absolute
nonsense conspiracy theory
this is not how the fbi operates this is
not how
the fisa court operates this is totally
out of nonsense and of course then we
got the inspector general report and
which pretty much confirmed everything
that
uh devin nunes had said so something
similar happened this week
with this uh story in revolving news and
then
uh tucker carlson took it up and then
significantly
uh glenn greenwald took us up and it's
now a really very serious question which
is
there that there are always people
mentioned in the indictment
unindicted co-conspirators and then
mysterious person one person two person
three
who for some reason even even though
according to the charging sheets
they played a very active role in the
events of january for some reason
they haven't been indicted so therefore
there's the next question is raised
to what extent uh did the fbi know what
was going to happen and even more
seriously to what extent was the fbi
itself
actively involved in instigating those
events in uh
in driving those events and in actually
causing
that uh riot to take place whereas the
people who actually were there
on washington on that day didn't uh want
this riot
um story and of course as you say the
legacy media is gone
haywire how how can you get these people
have a fair
trial if they cannot say well so it's
you can't say his name person a okay
but that's my that's my alibi that's my
proof
uh this is the contact i had with them
no no
no the state says you cannot reveal the
name that is a kangaroo report
dima the the thing that is so i think
you know because
so much has happened over the last few
years is it
if people forget that uh prior to
trump going down the escalator if we
could find that is a benchmark
is that the the press had at least
a pretense of an advocate adversarial
relationship
with the intelligence community with the
fbi with the cia
fast forward to today they're covering
up for them every step of the way
that you cannot interrogate the people
in power it is
terrifying and for people thinking about
because i mean i i have monitors at work
i see what on cnn and embassadors say
but they're all i mean it's all january
6. i mean
and they're building up to something
here and it looks like there is a major
cover-up we need to
learn more but i mean this is very very
destructive where the media is just
merely the mouthpiece
for the people that they were you know
technically
professionally supposed to keep an eye
on go ahead nima
well that's why i call president obama
the worst president in u.s history
you know it was under his watch
and you know formerly he was a democrat
you know
almost a leftist president it was under
his watch
that fbi and uh some special services
started
to be directly involved in elections and
and they were questioned about elections
and about their attitudes to politicians
it became clear that these people are
getting involved
but there is one point i think which is
important here you know president putin
mentioned
the january 6 story at his press
conference and i know that
some people on the left in the united
states took it back
you know we had some criticism from
peter cosning for example
i think when putin mentioned it he was
not taking the
right stand or the left stand just it's
a feeling of many people in russia i
remember 1993 you know
that was the last time when something
like january 6
happened in russia and of course we took
it very badly when we saw this man you
know one of the security
people at the capitol who just showed
that that woman who was not armed you
know
who was not threatening him who was
probably misbehaving but
he called blood in cold blood just shot
her dead
and and there was this video and now
people are getting 15
20 years uh even though they did not
hurt anyone and they almost were not
involved in violence
that's why people in russia are taking
it back it has nothing to do with the
russians being pro-republican or
anti-democrat you know they they don't
think that way okay
but but george i mean ashley babbitt i
mean
you know when what there's 14 000 hours
of footage
we're told uh we've seen snippets of it
uh some of it from what i have seen
counter
uh contradicts the narrative that uh the
the liberal consul of uh
league legacy media is uh portraying of
what happened there
but it seems and plus the prosecutors
need a lot of extra time
okay it seems to me that either you know
they have a blockbuster case or they
have no case at all
okay and they're trying to create one
because if
we never find out how ashley babbitt
died then this whole thing is a farce
from beginning to end
yeah yeah it it it really is um
and i mentioned about the 14 000 uh
hours
of footage we could even the defense
council
uh on behalf of the 480 defendants
are not getting access to this footage
uh and we can be pretty sure
that you know given the politicization
of the doj
that if this footage was really damaging
to uh the the rioters
we would have been seeing a lot more of
this now at the moment the things that
we do see uh
you know people pass around on twitter
on youtube or whatever
as you say they go against the narrative
we get
strange characters uh bellowing outside
storm the capital storm the capital and
they are being told by the
writers themselves you know he's antifa
he's
he know he's fbi he's an instigator why
isn't that person why isn't the person
who's saying storm the capital why
hasn't he been uh
indicted and then you got again the
questions like what about the leaders of
all these
white supremacist groups like uh the
proud boys and the oath keepers or the
three percenters the ones that
christopher wray and the others always
going on about how come
none of their leaders has been uh
indicted over this i mean they were
supposed to have taken part in those
events
so there haven't been that's what's
raising uh all of these suspicions
and then we've got the ashley babbitt
which is we're not even finding out
who the person was who shot her and why
did he do it
from what i can glean from what people
have been saying they know who
who the officer is the name has been
mentioned on the on the internet so uh
okay um but but this goes to such a
bigger broader point because in in
in the way the narrative of january 6 is
being presented
like pearl harbor uh 911
um if there isn't full disclosure there
isn't full transparency
it's there there will be parallel
narratives that will live for
a very very long time that cannot be
reconciled okay and this is my biggest
worry
and the it's the media that is driving
it is driving it
full steam ahead because it is still
litigating and judging the trump
presidency
if they trump resides in their brain and
there's nothing they can do about it we
we saw it with the recent summit as well
and you know so when the man leaves the
stage
is taken off of platforms he's still the
most powerful force in america
that's how they're building this it's
incredible go ahead
well first i would like to remind our
viewers that
on the day one when it happened we said
on this program
that of course this attack against the
capital could not be justified
it's it was a crime it was inexcusable
what these people did
uh the other problem the other question
is the reaction of the state and
the so-called investigation and how
all this turned into a new reichstag
fire basically you know
reichstag fire if you remember no one
now is even finding out if it was that
dutch communist
indeed who did it or uh if as hitler
claimed or maybe it was most likely a
provocation of the nazis
what happened later was much worse than
what happened
during that that event you know what
happened later was a
basically a monopolization of power by
one party
and we suddenly had 90 percent of u.s
media
strongly behind biden and uh not
expressing the views of a very
significant part of the american
population
and and the saddest
[Music]
of america consequ another part it was
not russia who did
it i i mean wait
okay i mean considering the arc of
history of the last five years
i can see george laughing here but you
know they're outside
forces and all right this was gonna be
you know it's gonna be a drama they
needed to be a drama
they and it's actually look at look what
russiagate did
it corralled in the progressives okay to
keep the democratic coalition together
they will do it again they're finding
another narrative to corral
their different elements of their
coalition to keep them cohesive okay
because joe ain't doing such a great job
okay at the end of the day
go ahead george one minute to you before
we finish it no no question
um there's going to be midterm elections
uh
next year uh at the moment it looks like
you know if we look at the uh
patterns in history the democrats will
suffer losses we can be absolutely
certain
that it will be russia and russia alone
that would be blamed for
any democratic losses i mean it's just
it's it's automatic
um and that's and putin said this during
his uh news conference when he said well
are you optimistic he says well i don't
know i mean it's very hard to predict
the dynamics of american politics so we
really have no idea how
uh what biden did uh this week will be
interpreted and reinterpreted within uh
american system
um so yeah there's no question the
russian involvement will play a role
but uh you know if we do find out that
the fbi itself
was actively involved in in the events
of january 6
then i think we're into a quite a
serious uh ball game
and then i think the legacy media will
step in and say
this is all a very boring story let's
move on
on that note gentlemen i want to thank
my guests in budapest and here in moscow
i want to thank our viewers for watching
us here at rt see you next time remember
[Music]
crosstalk